this Monday was tax day right well I
think it got extended uh two days
Tuesday so Monday you had to get in by
midnight to exactly but it's tax season
right now so when you do get your refund
two grand five grand ten Grand
maybe you don't go on vacation this
summer maybe you don't ball out at the
mall this summer I don't know maybe you
understand hey let me save that money
what is that job loss no it's 20 billion
left 20 billion less response on your
point gotcha thank you yeah so uh
during covid there was free money flying
around you know cash is trash uh nfts
were more popular than money in the bank
I think at this point we need to
establish just let's get back to basic
save that money understand if you do get
that tax refund be very prudent with it